hello everyone welcome back to the
miniature session and uh
as we saw i had already managed to
unleash one b3 on one and just uh
nine months leading to a checkmate and
also i had released my course
uh so i was really looking forward to
how the
world and the elite would uh treat my
course
and i was eagerly looking forward to the
start of the meldwater's championship
store where i was hoping to see
some of the top guys try 1v3 but
very big was my surprise when i saw none
other than the
uh reigning world champion play
not b3 but b4
yeah i honestly don't know whether he
wanted to troll anish or
when he went for one before against
whether he wanted to troll anish or
whether he wanted to just play one b3
and it was actually a mouse league
but either way it was very funny and i
don't care which of the reasons is true
and after e5 uh bishop to b2 bishop b4
bishop to e5
knight of six uh air magnus went for c3
and after bishop eson
actually he managed to get a very good
question and he was fighting for
more than equality he was clearly trying
for something and
but the game entered in a draw so in the
very
next white game magnus finally unleashed
one b3
against alexander grishchuk and yeah it
was
a huge honor and a surprise to see the
world champion follow not just any
direction but the direction which i
actually recommend in our course
so after b3 black goes e5 now we go
bishop b2 attacking the pawn on e5 and
knight to c6 on c4
we are taking d5 into our control and
this is the new direction which i
recommend in our course and after knight
of six
uh the point is to go knight of three
yeah of course e3 is also clearly
possible and very good to play
but knight f3 is also very good for
rapid and
blitz for our time formats so e4 knight
to d4
yeah it was like yeah i just still can't
believe that he actually played this
line yeah
i guess when you beat a super gm in nine
months it doesn't go unnoticed
so bishop to c5 knight to f5 and uh
the best part was alexander was actually
prepared for this line
and after knight f5 he went for the
competitive d5 line which is the
probably the critical test because short
casual e3 i think white keeps some pull
so after d5 now there was also a very
funny scenario which happened which was
uh we had this funny
hand and brain session where me and
vidit were
in the same team while we were playing
against any sources jordan
and we reached this position in the
friendly
matchup in just 24
and i think the move which i played i
was the brain so i said
pawn and with it took c takes d5
and the dutch guys went for bishop f5
and ddex c3
dxe6 e3 this is the only one otherwise
white is just better after e3 so
they actually played e3 f takes e3 okay
here they messed up
here if they had gone for b6 it was full
compensation for black
due to our v king but they went for
something like knight e4 and after g3 we
got a
clear advantage although we did not win
that game i think
mostly i have to blame i did not play
very well
after this so but the right one after c
takes d5 is going to xd5 i think this
is exactly what anish wanted jordan to
play but jordan
uh just went for bishop xf5 c takes d5
queen x defend after knight takes g7
king is on
and the brave knight on g7 meets an
untimely death
as there is no way for him to defend and
uh
after queen g5 the knight is just toast
yeah he is not coming back to life
uh but cd5 is not the way it's
inaccurate and the move after d5 as
shown by magnus carlsen
himself force knight takes g sound and
after king d5 only now you just take on
d5
the point is uh due to the threat on c6
black still can't take the
knight on g sound and now black this
model is forced to go for the swardling
bishop d4 uh because you cannot take
with the queen
then we take on f6 and if he takes with
the knight then the knight
uh we can throw the knight somewhere and
with the rook on h8 or just come knight
h5 with a clear advantage
so after c takes d5 a very important
move by black which is bishop d4
uh blocking the bishop's uh long
influence on the long diagonal
and now we just clearly play knight c3
we are like okay fine now you want to
close it we can close it
and uh here yeah there are two ways for
black to survive
and uh alexander did not choose the
right one
uh one of the ways was knight b4 and
here the epic move knight h5
just giving up the piece like you wanted
to take the knight on json you can take
it on h5 and after knight h5 we go e3
attacking the bishop on the knight at
the same time so now black has to find
the crazy murukji i mean if he doesn't
know this he's just gone
so he has to find this move and here we
just go for the very simple bishop a3
uh pinning the knight and you can see
yeah like how many pieces are attacked
in this three pieces are attacked at the
same time
how often do you see such a scenario in
any opening so black goes bishop c5
and now we have to take on b4 because we
really want to win back the piece on h5
so bishop takes b4 bishop takes b4 queen
to h5
bishop to c3 detect c3 now black goes
queen of 6 attacking the pawn on c3 and
now rook c1
this is like a force line uh none of us
can change
ship g for queen hi bishop f5 queen h5
bishop g4 with the first repetition for
both sides
yeah this is one sample line which could
happen of course if you don't know
there's no way black is going to find
this
i mean if grishchuk could not find it
there is no way your opponent is going
to find all this
so after a knight c3 if black goes
knight x d5 this is another crazy way
which computer at first doesn't agree
but then after a while he agrees that
this position is fine
so knight to h5 we just come back and
now e3 like what an idea yeah just to
sacrifice another pawn to weaken our
king's shelter
and after f takes e3 uh bishop takes
uh c3 detects c3 this is all the first
line i just wanted to show you to give
an
idea of how the lines could develop
queen h4 check there's no way this
happening in your game mostly
uh because black will not be aware of
this line so queen h4 check knight to g3
here knight takes e3 the most natural is
like a big error and after queen d3 we
are just clearly winning
so after knight g3 black goes knight of
six c4 opening of the bishop diagonal
and after rook g8 uh yeah black has
only one forced way to equalize which is
right while we have more liberty we can
do many things
and still it's equal so we go queen d3
this is a sample line
rook takes g3 h6 g3 now if you take the
rook we just take on f6 and we are just
clearly better so yesterday cointex g3
king d2
uh king d1 would also link lead to the
same after bishop f5 so
let's have a look at king d2 bishop f5
once again black has to find all these
epic moves otherwise it's just uh
lost for him so queen takes f5 rook d at
check
bishop d4 this is the only move making
sure that uh
black has to exchange some pieces to
reduce his attacking potential
so knight xd for e takes d4 rook takes
d4 check king c2
still you can note that we are a full
full rook up yeah knight e4
now black is threatening too much here
would be two on queen c3 so we just go
queen a5 and black still needs to be
precious for some more more to make a
draw while uh we are just
gonna chill i mean if he finds he makes
a draw otherwise he's just lost
and user root down so going back after
knight to c3 black was 90s on
yeah i think surprised by the old line
with v3 on some
depth of magnus preparation uh district
makes the fatal error
after which there is no way to survive
for him
so magnus like okay you want the knight
you can take it but at least give me the
bishop
so now the point is if he goes bishop e5
we just come knight h
and after bishop g4 bishop e2 and we
don't really
lose the piece and uh they're just
clearly winning with the extra pawn on
the black snow competition and a big
advantage
so pawn to e3 bishop to c3 detects e3 a
very nice move
or bringing another pawn into the center
king g7 c4 or the bishop
is completely rolling on the long
diagonal and after knight g6
yeah here this is the last time i will
give her the better uh solution after
queen d4
followed by long castle bishop b to g4
h4 white is just clearly winning
uh the more chosen by magnus is also
very strong but
uh yeah queen d4 is slightly stronger
according to computer but this is the
last moment i will give a
stronger solution let's just enjoy how
magnus crushed uh a world-class player
like
alexander krishna so g4 head six h4 yeah
continuing in the same spirit trying to
get g5 in
c5 yeah i think still it's too early for
g5 because black has this rook h1
uh x-ray on the edge file so we just
magnus like
bishop veto i don't care uh also it's
reminds me of uh girlfriend's famous
quote he's like any move any square
this clearly illustrates like how good
white's position is
like we have already two pawns and
black's king is weak and the bishop is
just dominant on the long diagonal so
this is just completely hopeless for
black black goes king g8
coincidental yeah magnus like i'll also
castle i mean i
all the time in the world you can do
nothing about it he goes look at someone
long castle yeah with this i think
black's last hope of survival is gone
and the breakthrough is going to come
along the h
or g file so it's long castle
uh crystal's like at least let me take a
pawn and go down fighting so
knight g5 and now a very nice h5 because
if we go rook g1
black can just solidify this question
with h5 so he goes h5 first
knight affair now it's like okay let me
take this important pawn on e4
f5 going to c2 he comes back is like now
i want to put the
rook g1 at f3 and the king is going to
be in big trouble soon
so knight of two rook g1 check king of
sun
all the pieces are just joining together
to make a amazing
um chemistry queen h4 bishop e5
queen e4 yeah blah blah is trying to
just somehow exchange coins but
magnus is not having any of it is like
okay now this knight is going to go
and after knight is three found a very
nice murk g4
and the queen is trapped in the center
of the board and the king is still weak
and white still has the very powerful
names a loss and bishop
yeah i think uh i think somehow i feel
like
i created some sort of revolution by
introducing such a
sideline and kind of made it into
mainstream
just due to the width of uh
the unexplored territories there i think
this b3 could become a very nice
uh weapon which you can use from time to
time
and beat very strong opponents
like i mean if this choke cannot deal
with the door in a rapid format
i mean i am pretty sure your opponents
are also going to have a very tough time
facing this one b3 so hope you guys
really enjoyed this miniature session
where we got to see my
uh 9 more victory and also magnus 25
more victory
so what are you waiting for yeah it's
time to start playing one b3 and become
a fellow cowboy
may the force be with you once again